hey guys dr. Berg here in this video I
want to talk about the best rheumatoid
arthritis tip okay and this is working
with lots of rheumatoid clients over the
years here's what you need to know
rheumatoid arthritis is an autoimmune
disorder your body has developed
antibodies attacking the joint the
joints are deforming rheumatoid
arthritis clients always have severely
low potassium levels that's interesting
and they always have low cortisol which
makes sense because cortisol is an anti
inflammatory hormone and that's why the
remedy for rheumatoid arthritis is
prednisone or cortisone shots okay
so here's here's what I found that
really will help you if you have
rheumatoid arthritis you want to bring
the potassium dietary potassium level
from the normal which is like forty
seven hundred milligrams up to six
thousand milligrams okay so we're going
from 4700 to 600 milligrams now some
people have a hard time getting their
potassium levels up to 4700 because
they're doing 10 cups of vegetables so
you may have to supplement with
potassium citrate but here's the point
when you bring this up to 6,000
milligrams you start seeing great relief
with rheumatoid arthritis okay with
swelling and I think the reason why is
because the tascam actually helps bring
up the cortisol to the normal levels
because there's association between
potassium of course oh I don't know
exactly for sure all I know is that when
you add this the person gets a lot of
relief okay and also you'll see that a
lot of swelling will go down too now I
put some links down below for like some
research that you can see the connection
between potassium and RA so you can kind
of study on it but that's the most
important tip the secondary tip that I
want to throw in there has to do with
another remedy called colostrum
colostrum it is a wonderful immune
building supplement that you can take to
improve joint pain and help remodel some
of the joints
it's probably one of the best remedies
for rheumatoid arthritis that I know as
well in addition to the potassium so I
think the combination of both of this
will be really really good for you and
you'll be really happy so I just want to
bring you awareness up on that I put a
link down below so you could research
that but go ahead and try it out and
then share with with me the result down
below okay thanks for watching